[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000. as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
today i am going over a topic that may
shock long time viewers it may
uh surprise longtime viewers it may even
horrify
long time viewers think i messed up that
quote but that's okay
i'm gonna talk about uh the nimzo indian
uh with the white pieces and i'm not
gonna play f3 on move four i know this
is this is terrifying stuff but let's
let's take a look at why you might want
to do this so the reason i first started
looking at the a3 nimzo indian also
known as the samish one of the
many openings that bears uh samish's
name
um the reason i started looking at this
is because i had to play in this
tournament called the master lab in st
louis i went over some of those games
over the past couple lectures
um but in the master lab of course is
national master julian prolago
one of my good friends who knows
basically my entire repertoire he knows
that i play the f3 nimzo he knows what
lines i play in the f3 enzo i'm a very
predictable person when it comes to a
repertoire
so
i wasn't totally sure what i wanted to
do against him because i figured he was
going to have something prepped
something to try to surprise me unless i
wanted to surprise him first so of
course that's how i arrived at the move
a3 on move four so let's go ahead and
put this on the board of course we start
in the nimzo indian which is
uh considered by many to be black's best
response to d4
assuming white allows it by playing this
knight to c3 uh and it's the nimzo after
bishop to b4 uh directly pinning this
knight
and then you know the game can go in any
number of directions so of course i am
one of the leading proponents of the f3
nimzo i i cheer whenever this move gets
played i think it's a great opening uh a
great way to especially get good
positions
uh against players who aren't quite as
solid against it as as they should be
um i don't want to call it a surprise
weapon because i play it as my my main
opening but it can definitely be more
unusual for players with the black
pieces to deal with they they're
probably not facing f3 nearly as often
as they're facing e3 or queen c2 uh or
even these other sidelines like knight
f3 where white just tries to develop
so f3 i think is a very good try uh for
white in this opening and i do think
that the lines sort of hold up now that
being said if black has all the time in
the world to prepare for you
there are a number of very tricky
options that that black can go for
against the f3 nemzo
and in particular i was sort of
concerned about this move c5 when after
d5 the lines are going to get very very
concrete and
sometimes it turns into this
sort of thing where whoever knows more
is going to get the better position and
might be doing very very well
um
and of course if black plays well then
black is going to be fine uh against the
f3 and himself but that's sort of almost
any opening in chess
so i wasn't sure what to do uh so what
do what what did i do i turned to our
grand master in residence at the time
josh ferdell for some wisdom
and i think this is something that you
guys can can sort of take home as well
what do you do against somebody who
knows your entire repertoire knows uh
which lines you like which lines you
play well you play something that's
almost your repertoire
you know that they've prepared for you
prepared for the exact ones that you
play
so if you can instead deviate a little
early and get into positions that are
similar
then you're going to have the upper
hands because you're going to know uh
the type of position better than they do
and they're not gonna have all this
theory mapped out so what's like the f3
nimzo but isn't the f3 nimzo of course
it's the a3 nimso
so let's first of all look at a position
in the f3 nimso and see how it's kind of
similar so against f3 my favorite line
to play against is d5 when we're going
to go a3
takes takes let's just say castles
takes takes e3 and now we want to go
bishop d3 knight e2 and play for e4 this
is uh the plan that i've shown a number
of times on in this class
so with the a3 enzo um
white is going to try to to do something
pretty similar so a3 and move four black
should probably take this knight i think
this is the only move that gets played
uh and then let's say black uh sort of
naively just plays something like d5
then we transpose into the f3 nimzo
lines that i like just very directly
we're already there
and if black does something like castles
then white's going to try to do
something very similar we might start
with e3 this time but we want to go
bishop d3 uh f3 e4 and try to to get
these pawns uh in the center rolling so
very similar to the f3 nimzo but it's
going to avoid all of you know these
lines and lines of theory that i'm sure
julian had uh had prepared for me
so before i jump into my game against
julian i want to show you the prep work
that i did uh to get ready for the game
and then i thought it might be fun to uh
go through my game with julian together
and see if my my prep pays off see if we
can punish julian in the opening
so the first one i want to look at is a
very recent game between pragnanda the
indian prodigy and andre acepenko the
russian prodigy
so battle of the prodigies this happened
at the tata steel masters tournament
earlier this year
and prague chose this move a3
uh scpenko of course takes on c3 uh we
get now c5 for black and this is really
uh this game shows pretty much one of
the only two main plans that i i've seen
from black at at the top level which is
what makes the a3 nimzo a really great
surprise weapon you know if black only
has a couple ways uh that they normally
play it doesn't take a ton of work to
actually feel confident playing it over
the board so essie pego starts with c5
we now we're going to see e3 by white
i really like e3 better than f3 in these
positions uh because
a lot of the time we can just play e4
without ever playing f3 and then we
might want to play f2 f4 in one go so e3
tries to save us some time over normal
f3 lines so e3 we get now knight c6
and black is going to play with some
plans that that do occur in the f3 nimso
sometimes so
uh who can come up with an idea or two
for for black here there's really only
two things that black normally tries to
do in these positions
um i'll put one move on the board for
white so you can just see and now let's
say black's turn here how are we going
to organize our pieces
yeah what do you think brad
um
yeah that's exactly right and that's
going to be one of the main plans uh in
in these positions is something like
knight a5 b6 bishop a6
and you'll start to see the pieces start
to gang up on the c4 pawn the very
common source of counter play for black
black does give up the bishop pair early
in the opening and so black does
normally try to prove that these two
pawns are in fact a weakness not just a
strength strengthening the d4 pawn in
the center and knight a5
and bishop a6 are a very common way to
do that
however this is not going to be the main
idea in this game that's going to be the
main idea in the next game that we look
at
so in this game
this is the more sort of forcing
variation that that black goes for
that's going to clarify the situation in
the center a little bit more quickly so
here black goes ahead and castles uh
white plays knight to e2 again we want
to leave our f pawn a little bit more
mobile we want to play f4 sometimes
actually most of the time we want to
play f4 it's kind of our main idea and
the knight on e2 is needed to support
the d-pawn before we can play something
like e4 right this is just attack twice
so 92 good move
b6 now for black follows the normal
normal ideas and e4 for white no reason
to wait on this move it's it's just a
good move to play
now black is going to play a slightly
unusual looking move but if you're
familiar with these positions it might
not surprise you so much so
white is actually making a pretty nasty
threat here so
let's say black continues with something
like bishop to a6
what do you think
white might have in mind in in this
position
yeah queen c2 so you're trying to
prepare e5 with the threat to the h7
pawn right
um so i think queen c2 would actually
let black off the hook just a little bit
there's um
there's a way for black to just
um kind of negate that threat
basically the move that black should
have played last turn black could play
in response to queen c2 so i don't want
to give it away just yet
yeah brian
uh i know white
often wants to play f4 f5
yeah so f4 f5 but um this is white's
normal kind of active active plan
um
but against white's most active plane
oftentimes black should just kind of i
think attack c4 so bishop a6 would be be
helping black the move i'm looking at
is actually this move bishop to g5
um this is going to give black
some pretty uncomfortable
problems to deal with actually this this
pin is not so comfortable
and you're not exactly happy with
playing something like queen c7
and uh
yeah i'm not even sure if if i want to
do this i think i can even just play e5
and i'm winning material very directly
um
like if this knight moves now then
there's bishop e7
uh and that's how i i was uh claiming i
was going to win some materials so like
even like f4 and the point now is you
can't really play this move as long as
this is happening and white's just
expanding through in the center very
quickly so
um maybe your idea of f4 f5 is is also
going to be quite useful here for white
because black's best move in this
position is 98 i think so kind of
unusual looking retreating the knight
all the way back but it it does stop
this idea of bishop g5 and it also gives
black an extra option against this idea
of of f4
so in the game prague continues with
castles and then we do see bishop to a6
and then as brian pointed out f4 f5 is
one of our main ideas and so that's what
prague uh starts to go for here
so i sort of listed this as one of the
more forcing variations because here uh
black needs to sort of deal with with
our threats if black tries something
like knight to a5 i think they are very
seriously going to start to get into
trouble after this move f5 white i i
think tends to get a little bit of an
advantage um in these positions like you
can still play f6 keep the pawns at bay
a little bit but these bishops are going
to open up and the queen is going to
have an easy access to the king side and
white's just going to start launching an
attack so not the most comfortable
for
for black at all and let me just
show uh how an example game went okay
this was not a good example game let me
show how this example game went
um here black tried king h8 uh for some
reason stepping out of some checks white
expands with e5 black does get to
capture this pawn but you can just
already see like after f6 takes takes
um
rook takes f6 is already a nice
sacrifice and the pieces just sort of
come into the position
i'm not saying this was the most uh
perfectly played game but you see white
is is just sort of rolling on the king's
side meanwhile these extra pawns on the
queen side are less than convincing in
particular with this knight on a5 a
little bit out of play
so outside of that
what can black do
right what is what is black gonna do if
not knight a5 and attack the c4 upon how
can what uh black try to prevent f4 f5
yeah brian sorry i think the point
behind 98 was so that like
f5
that that as well um that is the point
in this position so you want to go f5
you want to stop white from playing f5
and now white has to be a little bit
careful or else he's going to end up
kind of significantly worse right
you might be tempted to play something
like e5 here right you just want to keep
all your pawns together in the center
keep this massive center
together but i do think black is the one
that ends up on the better side of
things now after knight to a5 right it
looks like you have all this nice space
in the center but in reality uh black
has done a good job of keeping things
closed on the king's side all right our
powerful bishops are not actually
looking great stuck behind all these
pawns
uh and so now this this play on the
queen side is in fact going to be very
relevant you know rook c8 uh to come
takes one c takes on d4 takes on c4 the
rook's gonna start to uh invade over
here and i think black is is gonna be
pretty significantly better after
something like e5
so instead of that what white can do is
actually take on f5 and somewhat
surprisingly take on c5
so why take on c5 here like how does
this how does this move make sense we're
giving up our central pawn
for actually the the b pawn when you
really think about it
so why d takes c what's what's the point
okay that's actually going to be a very
important tactical resource in a couple
moves here so yeah queen d5 actually
very relevant to the position
but kind of more importantly
it's going to allow white to hold on to
these queen side pawns
if we play something like
knight g3 for example let's say black
takes some time to play g6 just to
defend
uh rookie one
okay well yeah let's say
uh black defense you do actually have to
defend your d pawn it's attacked twice
and then uh for example knight to
a5 we have to defend here and already
takes takes and rook c8 and this open c
file is going to be very much uh to
black's advantage in this position also
ideas of playing d5
and taking
advantage of of this this diagonal
opening up this file activating the
black pieces
so d-take-c
for one uh removes uh this idea for
black of opening up the c file and
number two as you said queen d5 is going
to be relevant it's also going to be
relevant that this d-pawn is backwards
on a half-open file so d takes c is the
second clarification in the structure uh
of course we started with e takes f e
takes f now d takes c b takes c
uh and now we are sort of nearing the
the end of the opening
um knight g or bishop e3 is how white
chooses to start
making a threat so black plays d6 now
knight g3 makes another threat so black
plays um oh
didn't mean to do that all right we'll
get back there we'll get back there uh
in this game scpenko plays knight to e7
which is very much not the main move so
after knight g3 here the best move for
black i do think is g6
uh and then there is sort of a a fake
tactic and by that i mean it's it's a
real tactic the tactic works but it's
just not very good for white so can you
find the fake tactic here
by fake tactic i mean real tactic
yeah it's
uh almost so it involves your idea from
earlier right queen d5 check is actually
a threat now if we can make it work
get rid of those arrows
so not knight takes f5 but
bishop takes f5 yeah that's right so
bishop f5 here and if you look in the
database i think this is the most played
move uh by far it's
played 18 out of uh the 30 games in the
quote-unquote masters database on on
lead chess now this is just a very bad
move um black takes back with the pawn
we go queen d5 check uh rook f7 queen
takes c6 uh but now after bishop to b7
this is why black played rook f7
uh queen to a4 it turns out black is
just doing very well here after after
something like h5
uh now why is black doing well
technically white is up a pawn but this
bishop is sort of a monster unopposed
this is why we're playing h5 we want to
go h4 put our pieces on the g file and
and white's going to be under a lot of
pressure here uh this knight doesn't
look great on e8 but it will look great
on e4
and yeah white's just not doing well uh
your counterpart to this bishop on b7 is
this bishop on e3 which is you know
problematic problematic to say the least
so bishop takes f5 just not a good move
uh not a good move uh instead just to
show you how your normal games might go
white needs to do some work to make
these two pieces make sense basically uh
once these two pieces make sense for
white then the position is going to be
sort of settled and i'm confident that
uh i can play this opening this opening
line without any issues
uh and that's something to take away
when you're trying to prep something if
you get to like move 17 you're like all
right this is it i've looked at like 17
moves i don't want to look any anywhere
else you have to at least know what your
plan is for your pieces because right
now this knight and bishop just don't
make any sense
uh so that being said what is the plan
for the pieces well
generally and we'll see this in the game
you want to go rook e1 to start
and then after something like knight f6
bringing the pieces back in you actually
want to go bishop f2 and the point now
is we are actually bringing this knight
to the very very natural e3 square where
it's going to defend the weakness on c4
it's going to threaten to jump into d5
and just be be an active piece the plan
for this bishop as well
this diagonal is no good this diagonal
is no good this diagonal none of these
diagonals are good over here but we do
have one active diagonal left the bishop
is going to be useful on h4 it's going
to help us try to invade on the e7
square a lot of the time so just to show
a few moves queen d7 for example knight
f1
knight e3
bishop h4
and here i would i would stop looking
looking at opening theory to be honest
you don't need to really go much deeper
than this you just need to know why are
my pieces on these squares what am i
doing with them and and how can i
continue for example
put the rooks on the open files look at
knight d5 ideas and
that that's really all you need here put
the rooks in the files white is going to
try to maybe invade on the queen side
maybe invade on the e file and black is
of course also going to be trying trying
to activate
so that's how it normally goes with g6
but in this game of course uh scpenco
deviates with knight to e7
and already i think white is going to be
a little bit better here
this knight just doesn't really belong
on the e7 square black needs to be able
to contest the e file a lot of the time
and remember where our bishop is heading
if it's heading to h4 then it might
actually be giving this knight some
problems on on e7
so uh prague chooses queen to f3 which
is a little bit weird in this case but
it's a fine move
uh knight to c7 now uh another sort of
deviation from the norm again this night
normally comes to f6
to look at squares like like knight e4
but of course it can't do that here
because we have not played g6 and our
pawn would be hanging
so knight c7 instead now rook a to b1
another perfectly fine move put the rook
on the file
queen to d7 and now prague does go for
the normal repositioning right fe1
bishop f2 knight e1 or knight f1 knight
e3 and bishop h4 so it's that simple
right uh essie penco deviated from the
theory uh prague i think took quite a
bit of time in the tournament
but he comes up with the same ideas that
we've seen before
and that's what it really means to be
prepared in an opening you know the
common maneuvering ideas in this case
rookie one knight f1 bishop f2 knight e3
and bishop h4
and from here esepenco actually pretty
quickly collapses
the way that he's organized his pieces
is not so good you know maybe he knew
all the theory at some point but he
clearly didn't really remember
how he was supposed to position his
pieces here
in the game he tried queen to g7 hitting
this pawn prog just simply plays rook b
to c1 and now after rook to e6 i believe
white is already pretty significantly
better
so see if you can find a nice idea for
for prague to kind of further weaken the
black pieces
black has a nice or sorry white has a
nice uh nice little concept here
so keeping in mind
one of our big ideas kind of invade down
the b file invade on the queen side
uh of course we're sort of annoyed that
all these pieces are attacking c4
and so there's one piece for black
that's sort of doing a great job of uh
hampering us when you look at those two
ideas specifically
so what what piece of blacks is is doing
the best at that
stopping us from invading on the queen
side attacking our c4 pawn
yeah the knight on b6 and as always when
there's a knight on b6 i know you guys
have seen this idea before
how can we harass a knight on b6
or a knight on b3 or even a knight on g3
or g6
these knights on these four sort of
symmetrical squares often run into this
problem
we actually already saw it earlier in
this game
not in this game but in the other
mainline
theory any ideas
so
indeed in this case as the the youtube
chat is saying a4 is is gonna be a good
move um this is
oftentimes like really really often one
of the most common things in chess
this is going to be a problem for
knights on these four squares
the earlier point i was referencing if
you remember
i think i can just jump back to it
if you remember in the
bishop takes f5 line
way back here uh with g6 instead of 97
in this line remember at the end of the
day this h5 move gives gives white a lot
of problems because h4 harasses this
knight opens up the g file and black can
can attack over here so just as h5 is a
good move against the knight against g3
um a5 or a4 is going to be a good move
here against the knight on on b6 just
trying to get rid of this piece trying
to open up the queen side uh of course
it is a pawn sacrifice which we see now
with knight takes a4
but this is not going to be great for
for black for a number of reasons so
number one this bishop is not so solid
now on a6 with an open file in front of
it uh this knight has been distracted
from attacking our c4 pawn
and uh prague does actually just have
a very concrete
concrete idea here for uh to follow up
so white to move here and sort of take
the initiative
we just sacrificed upon got to keep the
tempe rolling
yeah just knight d5 here and already uh
black is is probably not feeling the
most comfortable um you might think that
i can just double here make some threats
down the e file but my bishop on h4 is
actually useful
and i think simply here we're going to
take on c7
and if you
try let's see
now i'm always a little bit nervous when
i start just playing the chess moves but
i think something like this is going to
be quite uh quite nasty for for black to
deal with all this pressure
um down this line maybe actually maybe
i'm
maybe i don't know what i'm talking
about uh
let's see here there must be something
good okay i think rookie six
yeah it must be rookie six here
rookie 6 rookie 6 and then and then rook
a1 with the same ideas
um just we made these pieces a little
bit weak on the a file and now black is
is going to pay the price
so rookie 8 no good
um so what can what can black do well uh
bishop b7 is the move that icy punko uh
comes up with
and now if i'm remembering correctly uh
white is uh pretty close to winning
already what prague does is very very
simple he just takes on e6 and takes
control over the e file
so again just playing with the common
ideas we want to try to invade on the
queen side we want to try to invade on
the e file uh once we've activated our
pieces prague has already achieved
knight to d5 a very desirable thing to
get in this structure uh and so now the
the rest just comes down to calculating
out uh what the best way is to to sort
of punish black for the mistakes
so rookie one to start uh queen to d7 is
the move that uh sc penco comes up with
um already you have to look out for
ideas of this don't think it works right
away because our queen would be under
fire so rick f6 i think is playable
but that's why prague plays queen to g3
renewing the threat of knight to f6
uh essie panko chooses rook to f7 and
now knight f6 does just win
win in exchange instead if essie penco
had tried to capture this knight of
course now the danger is let's move rook
to e7
and you are in uh all sorts of a bad way
uh in this case
um
again i don't have the exact line i
think just queen to g5 is simple enough
and if you try to go here
i'm at the very least i'm i'm picking up
uh picking up
like this i'm picking up your piece like
this not the other way but but this way
should be good enough
so there's just no way for you to really
contest this rook i'm i'm invading and
checkmating you and
uh life isn't very fun
so
uh after queen to g3 that's why ese
panko chooses rook f7 but now this is
just an extra exchange for prague and
he's able to uh to win pretty
convincingly here
um i remember on the live show uh
there is a a rather shocking move uh in
this position that prague could have
played to win the game he chose to to
win through simple means just played
like queen to e3 but i thought it'd be
fun to show this one white to move here
and play potentially the the most
shocking move of the game uh in order to
win
uh very very convincingly
so to give you a little bit of a hint
black just played bishop to c8 because
bishop takes f5 was threatened like
let's say some stupid move
this is just going to be a checkmate in
very short order
rk8
game over
so that was white's threat
this is why black played bishop to c8
so what can we do
what can we do
i forgive you if you don't find this one
i would be very impressed
okay the youtube chat does in fact have
it i'm just going to reveal
very very surprisingly the move g4 uh
just directly directly wins uh in this
position
now the reason for that is taking like
this is not going to be good we get to
invade with queen h7 taking with this
guy is bad for the same reasons um
although i might be putting my foot in
my mouth a little bit
maybe we play this check first maybe we
go queen e3 now
um i'm gonna cheat
uh why is this so bad okay queen e3 is
the reason why it's bad when now rook f1
takes advantage of the open f file
um and bishop to b7 is actually an empty
threat we simply
take on f5 and say you have one check
and that's all you have
just a single check i cover all the
squares and and black is just busted so
g4 would have been a phenomenal
phenomenal finish to the game and said
queen e3 and prague does go on to win
without too many difficulties just
brings the pieces in
and rooks are more powerful than knights
so white is going to win this game
um
sooner rather than later just
winning all the pawns on the king's side
now
so why look at this game well because it
shows you one of the main plans uh
against
uh the a3 nimso right we know our idea
we know what we want we got we want f4
f5 we're keeping in mind bishop g5 ideas
and so one of the best ways for black to
respond is to shut down f5 by going for
this very concrete structure
and once we achieve the structure we
know our plans we want to go bishop e3
f2 h4 we want the rook on e1 we want
this knight to come around to e3
and that's how we want to organize our
forces
now of course the specifics in the game
are going to vary depending on what
black does but once you know this
position and you've seen these
repositioning ideas as played in this
game by the young indian prodigy then i
feel like you're comfortable right you
know you know where the pieces go you
know what you're supposed to do in the
structure
and
you know the the goal of your opening
prep is not to beat your opponent in the
opening it's to for me at least it's to
survive the opening and get a position
that i feel more comfortable with and so
that's what we've achieved uh just by
knowing this this little amount
uh so questions on on this
idea for black against the a3 nimzo
because it really is i think the most
common the the best are one of the best
ideas
so questions here
yeah so so far this was all very very
normal and then this knight to e7 move
is a little bit off
and then as far as the specific blunders
um
i'm honestly sort of forgetting the the
specific blunders i think knight to c8
is sort of a very strange move already
i think here though black is still doing
okay if i can cheat yeah black is a
little bit worse and the reason why
black is a little bit worse is because
this organization of the pieces doesn't
make a lot of sense
like i said this knight wants to be on
f6 wants to be aiming for the e4 square
this bishop kind of wants to come back
to b7
um the knight on b6 is okay but again
it's vulnerable to this idea so because
black has put the pieces on slightly
weird squares uh black's gonna be a
little bit worse but then yeah let's see
where the actual blunder is
um knight d5 bishop b7 takes ticks
rookie one
okay it it's here queen to d7 the second
time is is gonna be the mistake because
these knight f6 threats turn out to be
just too much for for black to deal with
um so instead of that according to the
computer it wants to play g5 which i
think is a hard move to justify
but knight to c7
is also going to be okay
when after apparently bishop f6 is a
good idea
um we're actually going to get trades in
a slightly unusual way
when again okay no i messed that up
king f8 gf3 okay i didn't mess it up the
computer just changed mine changed its
mind knight c3 in this case we're gonna
get an exchange down end game where
black has two pawns for it um and white
is still gonna be definitely pressing
and actually the more i look at this
position the more i think white might
win this game more often than he draws
this game
um but apparently this was just a better
way to continue for black apparently
also g5 is
some nonsense that i i don't want to
spend any amount of time thinking about
okay
so technically uh queen d7 is the big
blunder that makes the position lost but
earlier again this move knight to e7 is
the start of the sort of weird moves
that uh
make black end up in a position that's
not as comfortable as it should have
been
again just to show the normal lines here
uh rook to e1 this is how black is
normally organizing the pieces um knight
goes to a5 this rook comes to e8s and
this bishop comes back to b7 you see
black very comfortably contests this
file this knight and bishop work
together to come to e4 uh and the black
pieces just make a lot more sense
uh okay that's a good question though so
really quickly i want to show you how we
got there we got
with knight to c3 a3
and we saw this move c5 to start with
now we're going to play e3 not f3
because we want to save time and put
this pawn on f4 right away
bishop d3
knight e2 e4 and now black's idea knight
to e8 and if you go bishop a6 bishop g5
is a very very strong move uh when you
have to deal with e5 threats
and you can't comfortably play this
remaneuvering idea so knight to e8 now
after we go f4 black strong idea is f5
going for this structure
uh where we now know the ideas are to
bring our pieces around
uh bring this knight into e3 bring this
bishop end to h4 and play on the queen
side and down the d file and e file
and that's that's really all there is to
uh this particular line of the a3 nimzo
uh now let's take a look at the other
main plan which is going to show up in
this game which is actually a blindfold
game between carlson and lekko
so as stated earlier in the lecture uh
black does not necessarily need to do
this and instead as brian pointed out
this is going to be the most common plan
against this structure now this does
show up in that other line that we were
looking at you saw black was definitely
still trying to pressure c4 but wasn't
actually going to be able to win this
the c4 pawn whereas in this case black
uh four goes playing c5 right away and
instead of that black is just gonna do
this right off right off the bat just
come after your c4 pawn try to capture
that guy and try to to take the take the
money and run
so against this
somewhat confusingly we are now going to
play f3 uh and what's the point the
point is that in this variation after f3
uh b6 is not actually the most useful
move black is going to be able to play
something like knight to c6
and after something like e4 we're going
to go d6
and black is going to be able to uh get
get this structure a little bit more
comfortably where we're playing d6 we're
getting e5 eventually queen a5 here we
have immediate threats against the d4
pawn
so
uh against c5 i don't like f3 because
the d4 pawn comes under fire when we
play e4 right away so that's why i like
e3 you know we we defend d4 for a little
bit and we save time on f3 uh in the
long run now against b6 that does not
put the immediate pressure on d4 which
is going to make f3 a little bit of a
better idea b6 is kind of committing
black to this other plan of attacking on
c4
um okay no more cheating for anybody um
knight to c6 e4
is our idea bishop to a6 uh and now
bishop to g5 is gonna be the move that
i'm i'm recommending
so
uh in the f3 nimzo uh
you would have already seen black castle
and played knight e8 uh much like the
the lines we were looking at earlier
but in the a3 nimzo black has not yet
committed the king to castling king's
side and that is one of the reasons why
black in this specific position is okay
with allowing bishop to g5
so uh black should play h6 to start with
and then here um g5 is one of the main
moves but i also want to take a quick
look at knight to a5 so
knight a5 why isn't white winning a
piece
why aren't we winning a piece here
yeah brian
yeah
same idea we go g5
uh and at first glance this might look
really kind of frightening right like
you lose this knight on f6 i lose my
bishop on h4
but look at your king side structure
right um so
this is why black doesn't allow these
lines when he's already castled king's
side because your structure gets
fractured you have all these weaknesses
but in this case black is just going to
be uh winning out of the opening if
white were to go for this because queen
f6 black is going to take this pawn
we now do have to defend our pawn over
here and it turns out this g-file is
going to be really useful for black
rather than you know kind of a problem
this king can stay in the center for a
while maybe maybe maybe it'll castle
queen sight but the center is honestly
safe enough for it for the moment
so this line no good uh but white can of
course retreat the bishop here and
that's gonna transpose to the lines
we're looking at in the game
where lekko just plays g5 first so we're
going to drop this bishop back to f2
and now after uh queen to e7 uh let's
see if you guys can find magnus's idea
so what was the point of it all why did
we bring the bishop to g5 and provoke
all these these pawn pushes on the
king's side
why go through this whole charade we
could have just played bishop e3 in the
first place we didn't have to take this
long route to this diagonal
what do you think
we do want to play h4 it's exactly right
um so h4 already immediately threatens h
takes g
and i don't think queenside castles is
something black wants to do right away
although that is what peter lecko wanted
to do it looks like
um
but knight h5 is the other idea which i
want to look at first so i think i had
that in
in this other line so knight a5 first e5
g5
bishop f2
uh knight h5 again we still want to go
h4
against these lines as well and now for
example if black tries to take on c4
i believe white is already going to be
pretty significantly better you can't
take back with the pawn here because
after takes takes we are already playing
something like g4 and the pin down this
file is going to be really really
important so queen g5 for example and
now something like knight h3
and this uh weak pawn on h6 is going to
be a lot more relevant than white's pawn
on g2 uh g4 is going to come out as well
and this knight is going to hop into
some nice squares like f4 and white is
just totally taking over on the king's
side
um
so
that's why leko goes for g5 in this
instance and after h4 his idea was in
fact to queenside castle however here
white is able to immediately uh seize
the advantage
so how can whites uh try and immediately
go after this king on c8 castling
queenslade definitely came with some
pretty major risks
comes with some major risks here
yeah so queen a4 uh is sort of
superficially tempting but i do think
that knight a5 is a natural move for
black that solves
solves the immediate problem here black
wants to play knight a5 anyways again
we're still actually going after this
pawn
on c4 and that a5 does prevents you know
the threat to the bishop
so what do you do when you have a big
center
and your opponent has done nothing
to
to challenge it in the middle of the
board
yeah in this case white can very
effectively uh mobilize it and
uh prod some weaknesses into this into
this structure on the queen side for
black
i'm gonna be able to poke some holes
here
and wow the chats
it's in shambles
tonight people getting banned left and
right
so of course there's three moves you're
looking at right you're looking at this
one this one and this one
so i want to start with e5 because i
think it actually makes the the least
amount of sense here um e5 what does e5
do well it locks up these two pawns it
forces our opponent to play knight h5
which is honestly a move that they want
to play
and it makes our our job of playing d5 a
little bit harder right so e5 not going
to be the way way to go here
but c5 and d5 are both kind of tempting
in their own ways
uh not quite so i we can functionally
play d5 um you're not going to get away
with taking this um this is intention so
you have to take your first
um and then
i do think i am going to take with my
king but you're not winning a pawn or
anything
so d5 is playable
but do you want to play
i mean i think
yes so
uh c5 is is what we want to do uh it's
definitely desirable to play c5
now the thing is d5 first is going to be
a little bit stronger
in this instance and the reason for that
is not because we are super interested
in having a d5 pawn but it's going to
allow us to play a really annoying move
d6 uh in the following variations so why
is d6 so desirable well if we can get
rid of the c7 pawn
for something like c takes d then the
black king is going to start to be in
some serious trouble whereas if we just
play c5 now
let's say it takes takes
and i don't know maybe knight a5
yeah sure we can fix our double pawns
by capturing here but i think the black
king is is going to live to tell the
tale uh we didn't exactly rip open the
position on the queen's side king b7 is
going to follow and the rooks might even
come back to the a file they might
they're going to come wherever they're
needed over here on the queen side
um
c6 is not going to quite be working
and i think d-take-c would be an
improvement in the structure for black
so
i gotta stop doing that pressing the up
arrow
okay so that is why d5 is magnus's
choice in this instance
now that line that i showed isn't going
to be ideal for black because we do fix
the white pawns here
and
um i don't know if we want to play d6
immediately but i think d6 is is going
to be a strong idea as is something like
bishop to d4
um
i'm even looking at like c4 c5 again uh
when after knight c4 i might be
might be uh
putting some pressure putting some
pressure on down the c file
so rather than that black chose to leave
the pawns doubled with knight to a5 but
now this is going to allow c5 as a nice
little follow-up
so as you were saying it looks like
there might be some tactics here
involving taking on d5 trying to use
this e file
but first black has to deal with the
bishops being in tension and then
magnus's idea is revealed after this
move bishop takes f1
so we have a really
uh really nasty move here for for black
which i might have hinted at already
what do you think
d6 of course with tempo on the queen
uh and now
you know we can try to move away but
we're going to get captured on c7 with
tempo so takes
and then this is where magnus goes wrong
in the game he foolishly captures his
pawn back to leave himself with the pawn
on d6
and white's doing fine here white's
doing well doing okay
i think if i remember correctly but it
turns out
the peace sacrifice pawn takes b6 was
actually just completely crushing in
this game you can bring the bishop back
i'm gonna come here threatening to queen
try something like this become queen a4
rook b1 and all your pieces are are in
trouble and the black king has
absolutely no shelter left so that would
have been a nice end of the game
instead the game continued with takes on
d6 and they played a ton of moves magnus
ended up pretty significantly worse but
then managed to save the game at the end
of the day
played this piece sacrifice
got the piece back
tried to develop his king i think he was
still pretty losing
and then eventually uh they they
repeated moves into the game the game
was drawn uh that latter half of the
game not so important to us you get the
idea white was trying to attack the king
on the queen's side
so
uh the reason why i wanted to show this
game is because against the second big
idea uh in the opening bishop a6 knight
a5 we also know what we want to do we
want to go bishop g5 bishop h4 bishop
back to f2
and try to pressure the um the
uh king side for black
now if you're curious i think the best
way to play here with black is to go f
or knight h5 and after uh h4
i'm not queen f6 i'm actually going to
switch back to the other move order
because i remember it better
um i do like
knight a5 here rather than g5 for black
when we do go down the same forcing
variation but after h4 here rather than
bishop takes c4 this move f5 i do think
is is going to be good enough for black
to try and equalize for example takes
queen takes
knight h3 queen g6
and black is going to have some activity
over here uh something like g4 for
example is going to be very concrete i'm
sorry not not takes but bishop d3 queen
back
takes knight f4
and you get into some some pretty
tactical complications here where at the
end of the day it's going to be more or
less level queen to e2 finally defending
our pawn castles bishop e3
g3 bishop back to f2 apparently this
this game ended in a in a draw with this
but if i consult the big computer
let's see i'm sure there's some way to
deviate here
um yeah maybe instead of g4 yeah we can
just continue with with bishop h4 just
just play basically just play chess here
we can play g3 we can do a number of
things to just keep the game going
uh so that's where black i think went
wrong here i don't like this uh queen e7
idea in general from from lekko again
castling queen slide uh well it might
technically be okay
i do think white is is going to have a
much better game with these ideas of
expanding in the center going after the
black king
and going for the attack
so those are the two big ideas that i
looked at prior to the game just so you
have some kind of concept of how much
time i spent on this um i had never
really tried to study the a3 nimza
before from the white side and in a
couple of hours i felt like i was able
to confidently play this against a
player
who's a little bit higher rated than me
actually
so if you're looking to play the a3
names of yourself as a surprise weapon
like like i was if you spend just a
couple hours on it and you don't play it
like every game then i do think you're
gonna have pretty decent results so
what did all of this prep work culminate
into well of course culminated into my
game against julian prolaco in the
master lab and just to show you how this
went for all of my opening work i spent
a couple hours on
we got the a3 nimzo i did it and he was
shocked and surprised
um takes takes he does play c5 so do we
remember the move after c5
so c5 puts pressure on the d4 pawn so
what do you want to do
e3 not f3
um he played knight to c6 so far so good
bishop to d3 again we want to go e4
knight e2 these kinds of moves and then
he played queens to c7 so of course i
had not checked this move i knew this
move was probably wrong uh but
no need to panic because i know that the
common idea is for white here you want
to go knight e2
he goes b6 i go e4 and then he sort of
started surprising me he chose d6 here
so i go f4 again very very common ideas
and now after knight to a5
uh i immediately blunder so white is
doing pretty well here i think it's
around plus one
if you can find a good continuation so
this was my moment to prove that i had
defeated julian in the opening
preparation battle seize the advantage
and go on to win in glory which of
course i didn't do in the game because
chess games never go
quite as you expect
this is from master lap right yes
in the master lab so
of course what has julian done uh
that's different than the norm well in
the c5 knight c6 lens if you remember
black was often castling playing 98 and
meeting f5 ideas with f5 himself
so in this instance julian has refrained
from castling perhaps wasted a little
bit of time playing queen c7 and d6
unprovoked and because of those two
things
white's going to be able to to take the
advantage
by doing
what's
uh yeah so f5 is of course gonna be an
idea here but it turns out that the way
that julian has played has sort of
targeted targeted this f5 break
immediately right he's set up on these
dark squares we do go f5 i think e5 is
what julian was intending
when um
i wasn't entirely certain if i was going
to be be doing well here or not i have
to deal with these threats
and again
black has managed to keep this diagonal
closed yes the dark squared bishop has
opened up but i wasn't sure if it was
the best that i could do turns out that
there's there's something else that you
can do
on the chat is now deciding my opinions
on all number of things that i've never
talked about
mr e i'm glad i responded to your point
but i don't think i saw your point
yes so e5 here is going to be uh really
brutal for for black to deal with if you
try knight to d7 for example
um immediately now f5 is going to be
good we prevented black from keeping
things locked down
and i'm not even going to try to play
these uh from my own brain here yeah d
takes e5 fe 6 fe 6
castles for example and with this king
locked in the center it it's going to be
a big fight i've given up a lot
as far as my central pawns go but white
is going to be on the better side of
things with this black king sort of
really stuck in the center
um which yeah i think actually yeah the
computer prefers castling first is is
the best way to do it so we leave the
pawns in tension for a little while
longer
and then we're able to go f5 and if
black tries f5 himself we have a really
nice idea here of d5 when black just
hasn't coordinated well enough wasted
too much time on the queen slide to to
stop our ideas
in this direct direct manner
so e5 would have been great instead i
play this awful move d5
um
trying to remember some of these lens i
had looked at where
let's say castle's here if black had
tried e5 now d5 is going to be strong
because i can play f4 rip open the
f-file and win
um instead when i play d5 in this
position turns out to be very wrong
because e takes d5 c takes d5 is good
and i have i have a lot of trouble now
keeping my center together if you're
curious how this game went i'll show you
a few more moves black continues on the
queen side
um goes for a very concrete line that
wins the pawn turns out he would have
been a lot better off just playing
bishop g4 and kind of just playing the
position after h3 takes takes and just
playing for for the weaknesses in my
center
instead he chose this concrete line
uh where after now bishop g4
my queen has no squares
so i have to go to e1 and this allows
knight takes d5
uh turns out though this is going to
give me a lot of counter play i found
the best move h3 and then julian
unfortunately
in this position which is a very complex
position but uh
lucky me my opponent blundered sometimes
it happens he played this move queen e3
hoping that i would capture
and
capture uh i believe no not hoping for
that um
so his idea is if i do capture don't
have time to capture here because my own
bishop is hanging
and if i try to
take on
g4 then queen g3 and i do manage to go
up a piece here but it's not a very
happy piece that i'm up because i am
going to be getting checkmated in this
position
so that was his big idea but he missed
that i can just defend my knight and
then he has two pieces hanging and i
have no pieces hanging so this is going
to turn out well for for me
um takes takes knight d3 takes takes on
f1 takes on f1 and i have two pieces for
the rook and should
go on to win easily whether or not that
actually happened is a different story
but at the end of the day did end up
winning this game
so there you go that's the work that i
did to
prepare this surprise a3 weapon
and it's really not a lot uh if you only
have to spend an hour or two preparing
an entire opening line against the f
against the the nimzo indian defense
then that's that's very good
uh return on investment for for your
time right the nimzo indian is a huge
massive massive branch of chess against
d4 and in just a couple short hours i
think you two can feel confident in the
a3 nimso there's really these two big
lines to learn and then you know you can
do as much work as you want obviously
there's always going to be sidelines but
i felt confident playing it just knowing
these two big ideas and what to do
against them
so hopefully you found this informative
hopefully you also feel a little bit
more familiar with the two big ideas
against uh the a3 nimzo indian and again
if black knows all the stuff black is
gonna be fine but that's just gonna be
chess no matter what opening you pick so
83 nimzo one of my new favorite surprise
weapons and now i can never surprise
anyone again because as soon as they
google my name and a3 nimzo then then
they'll see that i know know a little
bit about this as well
uh it's the price you pay for for
teaching chess i guess
um so any final questions for me before
i i call it quits here uh we do have uh
women grandmaster katarina nemkova
coming in right after me uh with some
more fun chests for you guys but any
final questions
all right well thank you all so much for
joining as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
you